raphaël d'akbou au président de
l'association des amis de laurent gbagbo
bonsoir appel gbagbo
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france laurent gbagbo a été a bénéficié
d'un non lieu dans cette mise en
accusation pour crimes contre l'humanité
ils demandent maintenant à être libérés
les opposants ses opposants s'y opposent
les avocats dit on de la côte d'ivoire
pour quelles raisons pour quelles
raisons selon vous ici opposent parce
que ils ont plutôt bien mais moi vous
avez fait allusion à sa mémoire là
qu'ils ont produit que j'ai ici
empoissonné mois bon ça consiste juste à
dire que les restrictions parce qu'en
fait le cycle le en février le 6 février
ce qui va se passer c'est de les lever
toutes les restrictions qui sont
vraiment attentatoire à la liberté de
drones au bout et son avocat demande
donc on lève les restrictions qui sont
des récessions d'une rien à faire avec
quelqu'un qui a été acquitté voilà donc
ça consiste simplement à demander à
l'angle les conclusions de cette demande
qui a été qui a été déjà introduit par
ses avocats par les avocats du président
laurent gbagbo
on va voir quelles sont les conclusions
de deux secondes alors ce procès a
conclu à un non lieu parce qu'il n'ya
pas n'y avait pas vraisemblablement du
côté de l'accusation suffisamment de
preuves pour démontrer qu'il y avait
bien eu des cris nous incitations en
tout cas à commettre des crimes
lord et du bras de fer postélectoral de
2010 2011
oui qu'en pensez vous est-ce que
ces preuves existent ou pas sont
honnêtement si cette pub existait 82 de
moi qui sont passées on les aurait vus
3000 morts il ya eu il ya eu plus de toi
maintenant parce que la commission qui
était qui a été destitué par le
gouvernement qui est en place
actuellement en côte d'ivoire a conclu à
plus de 15000 morts et ses conclusions
n'ont pas été rendus publics
et c'est le gouvernement actuel qui
s'est opposé à cela parce qu'il y avait
plus de 15 mois en ont dit trois mille
morts comme citoyen mort c'était moins
importants que quinze mille mois donc
bon la question que vous posez c'est est
coupable à vos yeux ou pas d'avoir
incité ont tous bien de commettre ses
crimes personnellement si je le dis moi
président des amis du lombard odier
écoutez vous pouvez pas dire autre chose
que ce que vous dites
sauf que il ya la cpi qui est passée par
là les puits et après sept ans de
préventive sept ans et trois ans de
procès on s'est rendu compte que les
ceux qui ont déposé ces tels étaient les
témoins à charge
on s'est rendu compte que c'était mon à
charge n'ont rien démontré absolument
rien est ce que dit maître mignard et
mètres de moi aujourd'hui c'est que le
procès a été arrêté et que la cour le
procureur encore la possibilité de
prouver un certain nombre de choses mais
que pouvaient prouver le procureur qui
n'a pas prouvé au bout de 80 de témoins
qui sont passés il va y avoir des
élections bientôt en côte d'ivoire en
octobre si si on février
toute obstruction élevée quant à sa
séance en son séjour en tout cas à
bruxelles est ce que le président
pourrait se rendre à nouveau l'ancien
président ans pourrait se rendre à
nouveau en côte d'ivoire et se présenter
à ces élections
le problème du président le vent comme
aujourd'hui c'est de le gagner
la cote du vote c'est de la gagner 100
pays qui est son pays et lui et charles
blé goudé d'heure il a offert des
soutiens d'ailleurs en côte d'ivoire oui
absolument
il a des soutiens donc le problème qui
est le nôtre jour du mois en tant que
président de l'association des amis de
laurent gbagbo nous sommes engagés sur
deux objectifs le premier c'est le faire
en sorte que le président laurent gbagbo
nous saper la wind est le deuxième donc
de la gagner son pays le deuxième c'est
de cédric tablit son image parce que
quand même il à la cpi parce que une
campagne de presse s'est déchaînée
contre lui et a abîmé complètement son
image
ce procès qui s'est tenu a permis au
monde entier de voir que le pays en deux
mots n'étaient pas le violeur qu'on
imaginait donc notre problème
aujourd'hui c'est pas qu'il se présente
ou qui se présentent pas des élections
notre problème c'est qu'ils sortent de
là après la décision lui appartient
il est un niveau rien comme tout le
monde ils allaient droit il a des droits
s'il envie de se présenter aux élections
ce sera à lui d'en décider s'il a envie
de ne pas se présenter aux élections
c'est à lui de cette année d'en décider
également et puis il est dit en côte
d'ivoire on peut servir à tous les
instants le président de l'envoi bout
n'est pas forcément quelqu'un qui qui
qui cherche à devenir président pauthe
président voilà il a fait des choses et
ses opposants justement ce
ne veulent pas qu'ils rentrent
puisqu'ils disent que cela peut être un
élément perturbateur justement pour la
stabilité et la sécurité vous pensez que
c'est le cas c'est s'attirer pq c'est ça
qui est absolument ridicule
comment voulez vous que quelqu'un qui
est qui rentre dans son pays et qui n'a
pas d'armée qui n'a personne puisse
troubler la tranquillité des personnes
qui ont une armée et il ya quand même
une armée en côte d'ivoire il ya quand
même des forces de l'ordre donc a dit
voir comment la seule présence de
laurent gbagbo peut créer des troubles
j'ai trouvé ça ridicule c'est pire il
est en même temps ça enlève beaucoup à
maître mignard et habitant de noix et
les autres qui qui suivent aussi et
c'est à la fois ridicule mais c'est
misérable
c'est bizarre est ce que pour vous une
réconciliation avec alassane ouattara
serait possible bien sûr
dans quel état d'esprit et laurent
gbagbo aujourd'hui laurent gbagbo est
dans un état d'esprit il est dans le
même état d'esprit il a toujours été
je vous rappelle que laurent gbagbo a
couru toute l'afrique
ici on le lui permettait il est même
venu en france il a tendu la main
c'est lui qui a permis alassane ouattara
d'être candidat alors que la
constitution de l'époque ne permettait
pas à la jambe et à notre candidat il a
utilisé l'article 48 de la constitution
d'un lorsque d'origine burkinabé risques
d'origine qu'ils ont mis là il a dit
qu'il utilise l article 48 compte
beaucoup de personnes il a utilisé
alassane ouattara était candidat il a
toujours tendu la main il a permis à
soro guillaume qui était quand même le
chef des rebelles en côte d'ivoire
d'être le premier ministre il a cherché
la paix partout alors c'est absolument
ridicule qu'on trouve que sa présence en
côte d'ivoire d'un cv du double moi je
crois que ces deux là
12 yeux tout simplement merci beaucoup
raphaël d'akbou d'avoir répondu à nos
questions c'est moi qui vous remercie et
je remercie les responsables de la
chaîne qui nous donne l'occasion de nous
exprimer c'est normal tout le monde a
droit de s'exprimer et merci beaucoup
merci bon